This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This winter is going to be brutal. I mean, it is just going to suck. And if you're like me, you've been spending a lot of time at homes and smarts, and it's starting to feel a little claustrophobic, maybe more than a little, a lot claustrophobic. Though, if you think about it, were you actually going outside all that much before the pandemic? Modern humans are essentially an indoor species. We spend roughly 90% of our time indoors, and that was before the pandemic hit. This is author Emily Antis. And my book is The Great Indores, the surprising science of how buildings shape our behavior, health and happiness. Emily's book looks at how our indoor spaces are actually a giant mystery. There is so much we don't know, like there are thousands of
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。这个冬天将会非常难熬。我的意思是，它会糟透了。如果你像我一样，大部分时间都待在家里，你会开始感到有点幽闭恐惧，也许不仅仅是有点，而是非常幽闭恐惧。不过，如果你仔细想想，在疫情之前，你真的经常出门吗？现代人类本质上是一种室内物种。我们大约90%的时间都在室内，而且这还是在疫情爆发之前。这是作家艾米丽·安蒂斯。我的书是《伟大的室内：建筑如何塑造我们的行为、健康和幸福的惊人科学》。艾米丽的书探讨了我们的室内空间实际上是一个巨大的谜团。我们有很多未知之处，比如有成千上万种
bacteria and microbes living inside our homes and we haven't really studied them. So you know we spend so much time in these places that we don't think of them as exotic or interesting, you know if you're an ecologist you want to go to the Amazon or to Antarctica and maybe you're not that interested in the ecosystems that are in our homes. So there's all this complexity that we're just scratching the surface of. Today as we head into a winter lockdown we'll talk to Emily about how sunlight and ventilation and the tiny, creepy crawly things in our homes can influence our health and wellbeing, and how we can use design to make our indoor spaces so much better.
细菌和微生物生活在我们的家中，而我们并没有真正研究过它们。所以你知道，我们花这么多时间在这些地方，却不认为它们具有异国情调或趣味性。如果你是一位生态学家，你可能想去亚马逊或南极洲，也许你对家里的生态系统并不那么感兴趣。所以，我们只是触及了所有这些复杂性的表面。今天，随着我们进入冬季封锁，我们将与艾米丽讨论阳光、通风以及我们家中那些微小的、爬行的东西如何影响我们的健康和福祉，以及我们如何利用设计让我们的室内空间变得更好。
So let's talk about these microbes, which is the creepy crawly as part of your book. We haven't studied the bacteria and microbes that live in tighter homes all that much. What is living there? How bad is it? What kind of a forest am I living in? Yeah, well, so one study to start to quantify this comes from North Carolina and they studied several dozen homes there and they found that on average the homes housed 2,000 different types of microbes. So that is mostly bacteria, but it also includes some fungi.
那么，让我们谈谈这些微生物，也就是你书中提到的那些爬行的东西。我们还没有深入研究生活在我们家中那些更紧凑空间的细菌和微生物。那里住着什么？情况有多糟糕？我住的是什么样的森林？是的，为了量化这一点，北卡罗来纳州的一项研究调查了当地几十户家庭，他们发现平均每个家庭居住着2000种不同的微生物。其中大部分是细菌，但也包括一些真菌。
And it's actually more diverse inside our homes and outside them. And that's because the microbes are coming from a couple of different sources. So the vast majority of bacteria in our homes, at least, are coming from us. So we now know that our bodies are covered with and full of microbes. And when we move around to space, we are shedding them constantly. So that's a large part of what's in our homes.
事实上，我们室内的多样性比室外还要高。这是因为微生物来自几个不同的来源。至少在我们家中，绝大多数细菌来自我们自身。我们现在知道，我们的身体覆盖着并充满了微生物。当我们移动到空间中时，我们不断地脱落它们。所以这就是我们家中大部分微生物的来源。
But then there are also species that live in our homes. You know, maybe they're growing in the plumbing or they're growing in the insulation. One of my favorite home environments is the extreme environment of the dishwasher or the washing machine. So if you think about what's happening in there, it's mostly bone dry, which microbes don't like, but then every once in there, it's mostly bone dry, which microbes don't like, but then every once in a while it gets completely saturated with water, it gets real hot, you put
但也有一些物种生活在我们的家中。你知道，也许它们生长在管道里，或者生长在隔热层里。我最喜欢的家庭环境之一是洗碗机或洗衣机这种极端环境。如果你想想里面发生了什么，它大部分时间是干透的，微生物不喜欢这样，但偶尔，它会完全被水浸透，变得非常热，你放入
detergent in it, and it turns out that's selected for these strange kinds of black yeasts that don't look anything like any other yeast scientists have found anywhere. So it seems to be this unique ecosystem. And then finally, we have the microbes that are drifting in from outdoors. So things that live in the soil or in water and it attaches to us or it comes in through an open door window. So you have all these different sources of microbes. You're talking about another strange petri dish inside your apartment that you were interested in.
洗涤剂，结果发现这筛选出了这些奇怪的黑酵母，它们看起来与科学家在任何其他地方发现的任何酵母都不一样。所以这似乎是一个独特的生态系统。最后，我们还有从室外漂浮进来的微生物。比如生活在土壤或水中的东西，它们附着在我们身上，或者通过打开的门窗进入。所以你有所有这些不同来源的微生物。你刚才提到你公寓里另一个让你感兴趣的奇怪培养皿。
You sent in your shower head to be studied. What did they find in your shower head? Yeah, so shower heads are also interesting environments because they are also these sorts of extreme environments which are dry, the vast majority of the time, but then all of a sudden get flooded. And some of what they found in my shower head was not very surprising, so there was lots of bacteria that typically lives in tap water and in soil. No one was surprised to see that, but there were other creatures that were still pretty mysterious. My favorite is something that scientists have not
你把你的淋浴喷头送去研究了。他们在你的淋浴喷头里发现了什么？是的，淋浴喷头也是有趣的生态环境，因为它们也是那种绝大多数时间干燥，但突然又会被水淹没的极端环境。他们在我的淋浴喷头中发现的一些东西并不令人惊讶，比如有很多通常生活在自来水和土壤中的细菌。没人对此感到惊讶，但还有其他仍然非常神秘的生物。我最喜欢的是科学家们还没有
studied very much at all yet. It doesn't even have a real scientific name. It just goes by the very poetic RB41 right now. And two other places it's been documented are dog noses and paleolithic cave paintings. And so we have this bacteria that we don't know really what it does or why it's in my shower head and what my shower head might have in common with these other environments. It's all still kind of a mystery. So do these microbes in our homes, do they make us sick or do they make us healthier because we build up immunities to these things and other things because of them? What is this overall effect of them on us? As far as we know, the vast majority of these microbes are innocuous.
深入研究过的东西。它甚至没有一个真正的科学名称。目前它只被称为非常有诗意的“RB41”。它被记录在案的另外两个地方是狗的鼻子和旧石器时代的洞穴壁画。所以我们有这种细菌，我们不知道它到底有什么作用，也不知道为什么它会在我的淋浴喷头里，以及我的淋浴喷头可能与这些其他环境有什么共同之处。这一切仍然是个谜。那么，我们家中的这些微生物是让我们生病，还是因为我们建立了免疫力而让我们更健康？它们对我们的总体影响是什么？据我们所知，绝大多数这些微生物是无害的。
They don't seem to affect us one way or the other. And a lot of them are coming from us to begin with, so they're already microbes that are living in and on our bodies. But there are some on both sides of the spectrum. So like there are absolutely some pathogens, which I know is something we're thinking a lot about right now, you know. Some of us may have coronavirus in our homes. We know that certain kinds of molds can trigger allergies and asthma.
它们似乎不会以某种方式影响我们。而且它们中的许多最初就是来自我们，所以它们已经是生活在我们体内和体表的微生物了。但在光谱的两端都有一些。比如绝对存在一些病原体，我知道这是我们现在非常关注的问题。我们有些人可能家里有冠状病毒。我们知道某些霉菌会引发过敏和哮喘。
There are certain types of bacteria that live in plumbing that can cause like lung infections. But that's a small fraction of what's in our homes, and there's good reason to think that some of these microbes are actually good for us. So there's a growing body of literature that suggests that kids who grow up surrounded by a rich assortment of microbes actually are less likely to develop allergies and asthma and autoimmune disease. And the theory is because exposure to all these microbes early in life essentially helps
有些生活在管道中的细菌会导致肺部感染。但这只是我们家中微生物的一小部分，而且有充分的理由认为其中一些微生物实际上对我们有益。越来越多的文献表明，在丰富的微生物环境中长大的孩子，实际上不太可能患上过敏、哮喘和自身免疫性疾病。其理论是，在生命早期接触所有这些微生物本质上有助于
train your immune system so it doesn't overreact later on. Speaking of the microbes that are kind of good for us, you mentioned that, homes with dogs of healthier microbiomes. What, tell me about that. Yeah, this was satisfying to me as a long time dog owner and lover, but dogs introduce a lot of new microbes into a home, so they're the microbes that actually live in and on the dog, but then most dogs
训练你的免疫系统，这样它以后就不会过度反应。说到对我们有益的微生物，你提到养狗的家庭有更健康的微生物群。告诉我关于这一点。是的，作为一名长期的养狗者和爱狗人士，这让我感到很满足，但狗确实把很多新的微生物带进了家里，它们是实际上生活在狗体内和体表的微生物，但大多数狗
are going in and outside, and so they're tracking in soil microbes, stuff from grass, microbes from whatever they've eaten at the dog park, and for whatever reason, some of these microbes seem to be associated with our immune health. So there are studies that show that kids that grow up with dogs have a lower propensity for developing asthma and allergies and some of those conditions. So it's a bit tricky to isolate which microbes those are. That's something that science has not been able to do very well yet. But something about the community of microbes that dogs are introducing into homes seems
会进进出出，所以它们会带入土壤微生物、草地上的东西、它们在狗公园吃过的任何东西的微生物，出于某种原因，其中一些微生物似乎与我们的免疫健康有关。因此，有研究表明，与狗一起长大的孩子患哮喘、过敏和一些此类疾病的倾向较低。所以要分离出哪些是这些微生物有点棘手。这是科学目前还无法很好做到的事情。但狗带入家庭的微生物群落似乎
to be protective. And we've introduced a lot of products in the last few years that are antimicrobial, including window cleaners, and hand soaps, and floral cleaners, all kinds of stuff. Have they made our homes healthier? You know, I think it's a little too early to answer that definitively, but there are some worrisome signs that maybe they're having a negative effect on our home microbiome. So there is some research that suggests that the more you use antimicrobial chemicals in your home, like cleansers, the more that the bacteria there are evolving resistance to those chemicals. So that's one potentially negative ramification is that using all these cleansers could be helping to drive the evolution of antibiotic resistant bacteria.
具有保护作用。过去几年我们引入了很多抗菌产品，包括窗户清洁剂、洗手液、花卉清洁剂等等。它们让我们的家更健康了吗？你知道，我认为现在下定论还为时过早，但有一些令人担忧的迹象表明，它们可能对我们的家庭微生物群产生了负面影响。有一些研究表明，你在家里使用的抗菌化学品（如清洁剂）越多，那里的细菌对这些化学品产生抗药性的可能性就越大。所以一个潜在的负面后果是，使用所有这些清洁剂可能正在助长抗生素耐药细菌的进化。
The other potential problem is that cleaning with something like that is sort of a cropped-us-door approach and you might be wiping out the microbes that are good for us along with anything dangerous. So I think there's reason to be pretty cautious using these products. In terms of indoor health, the biggest factor might be air quality, and it's another factor that we don't know much about. So how bad is the air that we're breathing indoors? Yeah, well, so that's one of the things that we're still trying to get a better handle on. I mean, one trend that does seem apparent is at least here in the US in most places outdoor air has gotten much better over, of course the 20th century. And partly that's because of regulation.
另一个潜在的问题是，用这种东西清洁是一种“一刀切”的方法，你可能会在清除危险物质的同时，也消灭了对我们有益的微生物。所以我认为使用这些产品需要非常谨慎。就室内健康而言，最大的因素可能是空气质量，这也是我们知之甚少的另一个因素。那么我们呼吸的室内空气有多糟糕？是的，这是我们仍在努力更好地掌握的事情之一。我的意思是，一个似乎很明显的趋势是，至少在美国的大多数地方，室外空气在20世纪有了很大的改善。部分原因是监管。
We have brought down emissions. But one result of that is that for many people, their primary source of exposure to air pollution happens indoors now. So that comes from all sorts of sources. Some of it is just the products we fill our homes with. So, you know, things like our sofa, our flooring, all of our personal care products, just release all of these chemicals into the air.
我们降低了排放。但结果之一是，对许多人来说，他们接触空气污染的主要来源现在发生在室内。这来自各种各样的来源。其中一些只是我们用来填充房屋的产品。所以，你知道，像我们的沙发、地板、我们所有的个人护理产品，都会将所有这些化学物质释放到空气中。
But then our own behavior and activities inside our homes can also generate pollution. So cooking and cleaning are the big ones that are known to generate these big spikes in air pollution. Yeah, air quality is an understudied problem, but it's not a new problem. You have this whole chapter on ventilation in health. And you talk about how Florence Nightingale used to advocate for open windows and hospitals. And that was back in the 19th century.
但我们自己在室内的行为和活动也会产生污染。所以烹饪和清洁是已知的产生这些空气污染高峰的主要原因。是的，空气质量是一个研究不足的问题，但它不是一个新问题。你有一整章关于通风和健康的内容。你谈到了弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔过去如何在医院提倡开窗。那是在19世纪。
And I was thinking about this the last time I was in a hospital and it was not open at all. Like there was no fresh air. It was totally sealed up. Can you talk about the back and forth of how we see ventilation? Yeah, so there's been an interesting history here and hospitals several centuries ago were not a place you would want to go if you were sick. If you could afford it, you would want to go if you were sick.
我上次在医院时就在想这个问题，那里根本没有开窗。就像没有新鲜空气一样。它完全被密封了。你能谈谈我们对通风的看法是如何反复变化的吗？是的，这里有一段有趣的历史，几个世纪前的医院如果你生病了，你根本不会想去那里。如果你负担得起，你会想去那里。
If you could afford it, you would get a doctor to come to you. And so hospitals were really, they were dirty, they were unhygienic, they were overcrowded. In some places patients even shared not just rooms, but beds, which you can imagine is not great for the spread of infectious disease. And Florence Nightingale was one of these reformers who came along and advocated better sanitation, like basic stuff that now we sort of take for granted, like actually adequate drainage in a hospital room, so fluids weren't just sitting there and opening windows and daylight.
如果你负担得起，你会请医生来看你。所以医院真的很脏，不卫生，过度拥挤。在某些地方，病人甚至不仅共用房间，还共用床位，你可以想象这对传染病的传播有多么不利。弗洛伦斯·南丁格尔是那些进行改革的人之一，她提倡更好的卫生条件，比如我们现在认为理所当然的基本东西，比如医院房间里实际充足的排水系统，这样液体就不会积聚在那里，还有打开窗户和自然光。
And one of the interesting things was that she didn't really understand the mechanism of infectious disease. I mean, nobody did it at that time. Germ theory was not a widely accepted disease mechanism, but she intuitive and she observed that patients did better when she let more fresh air in and let more light in. And that was a trend in hospital design for a short period of time towards the end of the 19th century, especially.
有趣的一点是，她并不真正了解传染病的机制。我的意思是，当时没有人了解。细菌理论并不是一种被广泛接受的疾病机制，但她凭直觉观察到，当她让更多新鲜空气和光线进入时，病人的情况会好转。在19世纪末，这在医院设计中曾有一段短时间的趋势，尤其是。
But then when germ theory did become more widely accepted, and we had antisepsis and antimicrobial chemicals and technology improved, we sort of moved in the other direction. And hospitals began to close themselves up, and rely on chemicals for disinfection and technology, and they became these hermetically sealed spaces. And I think one thing we have learned is that we have gone too far in that direction, and we need to figure out ways to create more permeability between our indoor and our outdoor spaces. I mean, right now, in this current health crisis,
但当细菌理论被更广泛地接受，我们有了防腐、抗菌化学品和技术进步后，我们朝着另一个方向发展了。医院开始封闭自己，依赖化学品进行消毒和技术，它们变成了这些密封的空间。我认为我们学到的一件事是，我们在那个方向上走得太远了，我们需要想办法在室内和室外空间之间创造更多的渗透性。我的意思是，现在，在当前的健康危机中，
we're learning about the importance of ventilation all over again. What do you make of that? Even before the pandemic hit, I think there was a slow growing realization that indoor air quality was important and that ventilation was important, but the pandemic has absolutely accelerated that trend and made a lot of people think a lot more about air quality and ventilation than I bet they ever
我们正在重新学习通风的重要性。你对此有何看法？即使在疫情爆发之前，我认为人们也逐渐意识到室内空气质量很重要，通风也很重要，但疫情绝对加速了这一趋势，让很多人比我敢打赌他们以前想得更多地考虑空气质量和通风。
had before. And we know that increasing ventilation and bringing in more fresh air from outside and changing the air over more often can all really reduce the spread of infectious disease indoors. I think some of the improvements that we are thinking about making now, and here I'm thinking particularly about what's happening in schools where school ventilation systems are being overhauled and improved will have a lot of dividends even when the pandemic is over. Like we know that improving ventilation can improve our cognitive performance and could improve student learning at schools and schools have been sort of criminally underventilated in America for a long time. And so this is not how anyone would have wanted schools to be overhauling their ventilation systems, but it's long overdue. And I'm hoping that the pandemic will lead to improvements in that regard that pay off for a long time.
我们知道，增加通风、引入更多室外新鲜空气并更频繁地更换空气，确实可以减少传染病在室内的传播。我认为我们现在正在考虑进行的一些改进，在这里我特别想到学校正在发生的事情，学校的通风系统正在进行彻底检修和改进，即使在疫情结束后也会带来很多红利。比如我们知道改善通风可以提高我们的认知能力，可以改善学生的学习，而在美国，学校长期以来一直处于严重通风不足的状态。所以这不是任何人希望学校彻底检修其通风系统的方式，但这早就该做了。我希望疫情能在这方面带来改善，并长期发挥作用。
Is the solution for making a healthier indoor space is just to make it more like the outdoors? Is that what we're learning? Well, that is one of the ironies of what I learned when researching the book that I was not necessarily expecting that. You know, I talk about how I'm an indoor-z person and I wasn't necessarily expecting one of the takeaway lessons to be, to create a healthy indoor space, make it more like the outdoors. But that does seem to be a lesson.
让室内空间更健康的解决方案就是让它更像室外吗？我们学到的是这个吗？嗯，这是我在研究这本书时学到的讽刺之处之一，我并不一定预料到这一点。你知道，我谈到我是一个“室内派”，我并不一定预料到其中一个收获是：要创造一个健康的室内空间，就让它更像室外。但这似乎确实是一个教训。
So it applies to fresh air, but bringing in sunlight, bringing in elements of nature, bringing in outdoor microbes, all of those things seem to have a variety of health benefits. More in nature. It seems like it's connected to learning about dog noses and cave paintings. It feels like we keep forgetting that we're actually animals and we have to keep learning that. Yeah, absolutely. And we now know that they're ecosystems in our homes, but we are also part of those ecosystems.
所以它适用于新鲜空气，但引入阳光、引入自然元素、引入室外微生物，所有这些似乎都有各种健康益处。更多地接触自然。这似乎与了解狗的鼻子和洞穴壁画有关。感觉我们总是忘记我们实际上是动物，我们必须不断学习这一点。是的，绝对是。我们现在知道我们家中存在生态系统，但我们也是这些生态系统的一部分。
They're not systems that exist separate from us. We affect the microbes that colonize our homes and they affect us back and the same thing with insects and rodents and all sorts of other stuff that might be living in our homes. Right now, designers are coming up with new ways to combat the bad air and the bad lighting and all the unhealthy parts of life indoors. And while those design solutions are really promising, sometimes they have unintended consequences. So Emily, you talk about this Bronx housing development that was designed to make its residents
它们不是独立于我们而存在的系统。我们影响着在我们家中定居的微生物，它们也反过来影响我们，昆虫、啮齿动物以及可能生活在我们家中的各种其他东西也是如此。目前，设计师们正在想出新的方法来对抗室内糟糕的空气、糟糕的照明和生活中所有不健康的部分。虽然这些设计方案确实很有前景，但有时它们也会产生意想不到的后果。所以艾米丽，你谈到了这个布朗克斯的住房开发项目，它的设计初衷是为了让居民
more healthy. What did they do? This is a housing development known as Arbor House and it was designed with the principles of what has become known as active design and the idea behind active design is can we subtly encourage people to get more physical activity just as part of it. They're everyday lives. So, you know, without telling them to go to the gym three days a week, and it's based on research that shows that even just a modest increase in physical activity, so, you know, climbing three flights of stairs a day can have long-term benefits for our health. So, Arbor House is a eight eight story affordable housing complex in the Bronx,
更健康。他们做了什么？这是一个被称为“Arbor House”的住房开发项目，它的设计原则是后来被称为“主动设计”的理念，主动设计的理念是：我们能否在人们的日常生活中微妙地鼓励他们进行更多的体育活动？所以，你知道，不用告诉他们每周去三次健身房，它是基于研究的，该研究表明，即使是适度的体育活动增加，比如，你知道，每天爬三层楼梯，也能对我们的健康产生长期益处。所以，Arbor House是布朗克斯的一个八层经济适用房综合体，
and it opened in 2013, and it has all sorts of features that are designed to make physical activity, appealing, fun, and sort of part of the default behavior. So the most obvious example has to do with stairs and elevators. If you think about any high-rise building you go into that has elevators, normally they're the first thing you see. They're gleaming. They're prominent in the lobby. And if you can find the stairs at all, they're hidden behind a heavy fire door and it's flickering fluorescent lights and it's just not appealing.
它于2013年开放，它具有各种旨在使体育活动变得吸引人、有趣并成为默认行为的功能。所以最明显的例子与楼梯和电梯有关。如果你想到你进入的任何有电梯的高层建筑，通常它们是你看到的第一件事。它们闪闪发光。它们在大厅里很显眼。如果你能找到楼梯，它们通常隐藏在沉重的防火门后面，闪烁着荧光灯，一点也不吸引人。
But the principles of active design, and which were used here at Arbor House, really try to flip the script. So how can we make the stairs more appealing and more fun and did a fault behavior? So they've done that in a couple of ways here. There are motivational signs by the elevators that encourage residents to take the stairs instead, which a number of studies suggest is effective.
但主动设计的原则，也就是在Arbor House这里使用的原则，确实试图改变这种状况。那么我们如何让楼梯更吸引人、更有趣并成为默认行为呢？他们在这里通过几种方式做到了这一点。电梯旁有激励性的标志，鼓励居民改走楼梯，许多研究表明这是有效的。
But then there are also things like there's art hanging in the stairwells, and there's music playing in the stairwells, which residents and focus groups have said they and their kids actually liked so much that it made them take the stairs more often. And then there are more subtle things too. The stairs are wide, and they're well lit, and they're safe, which isn't always true in some of these affordable housing complexes
但也有一些东西，比如楼梯间里挂着艺术品，楼梯间里播放着音乐，居民和焦点小组表示，他们和他们的孩子实际上非常喜欢这些，这让他们更经常地走楼梯。还有一些更微妙的事情。楼梯很宽，光线充足，而且很安全，这在一些经济适用房综合体中并不总是如此，
that were residents who said, you know, they didn't feel safe taking the stairs at their old apartment buildings because it was dark and you couldn't see who else was in there. But here it's open and visible and prominent. That's one set of strategies that designers can use to encourage more physical activity there others as well. And there's some drawbacks to pushing people to use stairs like it seems like you can make the stairs more appealing but you could also make the elevators less convenient which doesn't serve everyone in the population. Yeah that's a really good point and that is the big drawback I think
有居民说，你知道，他们觉得在旧公寓楼里走楼梯不安全，因为那里很黑，你看不见还有谁在里面。但在这里，它是开放、可见且显眼的。这是一套设计师可以用来鼓励更多体育活动的策略，当然还有其他策略。而且推动人们使用楼梯也有一些缺点，比如看起来你可以让楼梯更吸引人，但你也可以让电梯变得不那么方便，这并不能服务于人口中的每个人。是的，这是一个非常好的观点，我认为这是关于某些主动设计策略时最大的缺点。
about when it comes to certain strategies for active design. And in fact, Arbor House has employed one strategy that I don't think is great from an accessibility standpoint, which is to deliberately slow down the elevators. That, as you can imagine, is an incredible inconvenience for people who can't or don't want to use the stairs. So I do think that some of these strategies are much better choices from an accessibility standpoint. So as you can imagine, adding art and music to a stairwell is not going to inconvenience
事实上，Arbor House采用了一种我认为从无障碍角度来看并不好的策略，那就是故意减慢电梯的速度。正如你可以想象的那样，这对那些不能或不想使用楼梯的人来说是一个极大的不便。所以我确实认为，从无障碍角度来看，其中一些策略是更好的选择。所以正如你可以想象的那样，在楼梯间增加艺术和音乐不会给
someone who can't take the stairs. But slowing the elevators down does, so can things like skip stop elevators, which only open every other floor, which is another strategy. So I think designers need to be really careful about which of these techniques they employ. Emily Anthos will tell us about one incredibly easy trick to make our homes healthier after this. So I want to talk a little bit about other sort of design solutions for making the inside healthier. A lot of designers are thinking about smart homes as way of making the indoors healthier with like sensors that open the windows if there's bad air quality or
那些不能走楼梯的人带来不便。但减慢电梯速度会，像“跳层电梯”这样的东西也会，它只在每隔一层楼停靠，这是另一种策略。所以我认为设计师需要非常小心他们采用哪些技术。艾米丽·安蒂斯将在之后告诉我们一个让我们的家更健康的极其简单的技巧。所以我想谈谈其他一些让室内更健康的设计方案。许多设计师正在考虑将智能家居作为让室内更健康的一种方式，比如如果空气质量不好就打开窗户的传感器，或者
that call 911 automatically if someone falls. A lot of this stuff, it feels very designing, it feels you know very utopian. I have to admit I find it kind of dystopian, how do you feel about smart homes and their promise? I think it is both and there are, you know, it can be utopian and dystopian and in fact the same devices and technology can be both depending on how it's used. I mean, I think there is enormous potential here, especially when you look at some of the sectors where it's being applied first, you know, I write a lot about the senior care community I think there is enormous potential here, especially when you look at some of the sectors where it's being applied first, I write a lot about the senior care community,
如果有人摔倒就自动拨打911。很多这些东西，感觉非常设计感，感觉你知道非常乌托邦。我必须承认我发现它有点反乌托邦，你对智能家居及其前景感觉如何？我认为它既是乌托邦也是反乌托邦，事实上，同样的设备和技术可以根据使用方式的不同而兼具两者。我的意思是，我认为这里有巨大的潜力，特别是当你看看它首先被应用的一些领域时，你知道，我写了很多关于老年护理社区的内容，我认为这里有巨大的潜力，特别是当你看看它首先被应用的一些领域时，我写了很多关于老年护理社区的内容，
and we don't have a great system of senior care here in the US, and lots of seniors want to continue to live independently in their own homes, but often that's difficult, especially if they're living alone. I think there is potential there for technology to make that safer, whether that's sensors built into the floor that can detect a fall or a smart oven sensor that can remind someone with dementia to turn off the oven. There's a lot of risk there too.
我们这里在美国没有一个很好的老年护理系统，许多老年人希望继续在自己的家中独立生活，但这通常很困难，特别是如果他们独自居住的话。我认为技术有潜力让这种生活更安全，无论是内置在地板中可以检测跌倒的传感器，还是可以提醒痴呆症患者关掉烤箱的智能烤箱传感器。这里也有很大的风险。
When you think about the senior care community that raises even, I guess, stickier questions of consent, I talked to some researchers who said people's middle-aged children were really excited to install these monitoring systems, but the seniors themselves were not necessarily always open to them. So there are a lot of dangers here too. Okay, so if people are listening to this
当你想到老年护理社区时，这甚至提出了更棘手的同意问题，我采访了一些研究人员，他们说人们的中年子女非常兴奋地安装这些监控系统，但老年人自己并不一定总是对它们持开放态度。所以这里也有很多危险。好的，所以如果人们正在听这个，
and they're in their homes most likely, 90% chance they're in their home listening to this, what could they do to make their home healthier right now? Like what would you tell someone to do to make their house a healthier place? One thing we haven't talked about yet, which is probably my top recommendation for everyone is nature. There is just an incredible body of research that demonstrates that exposure to nature has enormous and wide-ranging benefits
而且他们很可能在家里，有90%的机会他们是在家里听这个，他们现在能做些什么来让他们的家更健康？比如你会告诉别人做什么来让他们的房子成为一个更健康的地方？我们还没有谈到的一件事，这可能是每个人最推荐的建议，那就是自然。有令人难以置信的研究表明，接触自然有巨大且广泛的益处，
from reducing stress and pain to boosting mood, concentration, productivity, improving the immune system, I mean almost you name it nature benefits it. And the interesting thing about it is that it doesn't seem to have to be a particular kind of nature. So a lot of the original studies were done on views and they found that like people who had views of natural landscapes recovered faster from surgery than those who didn't. And so if you have views of natural landscapes, recovered faster from surgery than those who didn't. And so if you have views of natural landscapes, that's great. But studies suggest that even something like bringing houseplants into your home has some
从减轻压力和疼痛到提振情绪、专注力、生产力、改善免疫系统，我的意思是几乎你能想到的自然都有益处。有趣的是，它似乎不必是某种特定的自然。所以很多最初的研究是关于景观的，他们发现那些能看到自然景观的人比那些不能看到的人从手术中恢复得更快。所以如果你能看到自然景观，那很好。但研究表明，即使是像把室内植物带进家里也有一些
of the same benefits. And so does nature imagery. So putting photographs of natural landscapes up on your wall can help. And so interestingly, do nature sounds. So listening to bird song or babbling brook or something over speakers or over your headphones can have some of the same stress alleviating effects. So any way you can find to bring some element of greenery
同样的益处。自然图像也是如此。所以把自然景观的照片挂在墙上会有帮助。有趣的是，自然声音也是如此。所以通过扬声器或耳机听鸟鸣、潺潺溪流或其他东西可以产生一些同样的缓解压力的效果。所以任何你能找到的引入绿色元素的方法
or nature of the natural world into your living space, I highly recommend. I like that you could play bird song and it would help you out. That's brilliant. And actually, even I believe there's a study that even fake plants, like plastic plants, like if you like house plants,
或自然世界进入你的生活空间，我都强烈推荐。我喜欢你可以播放鸟鸣声，它会帮助你。这太棒了。事实上，甚至我相信有一项研究表明，即使是假植物，比如塑料植物，如果你喜欢室内植物，
but you just really have a black thumb, you could maybe get some of the same stress relief from bringing in some foe greenery. That's amazing. That's amazing. Yeah, well, the research suggests, and most scientists think that this is a psychologically mediated effect, and they explain it with what's known as the biofilia hypothesis, which is
但你真的没有园艺天赋，你也许可以从引入一些人造绿色植物中获得一些同样的压力缓解。这太棒了。这太棒了。是的，研究表明，大多数科学家认为这是一种心理调节效应，他们用所谓的“亲生物假说”来解释它，即
that because of how we evolved, sort of out in the rough and tumble of nature, we have this affinity for and attraction to nature. And so, whether it's an actual landscape out the window or a photo of a landscape on the wall, it sort of catches our attention, it engages us, it serves as a positive distraction, sort of taking our mind off of whatever might be stressing us out, our pain, and the other benefits sort of follow from that psychological, positive distraction. So let's talk a little bit about COVID and things that we might be able to continue on. So a lot of us have been thinking differently about the indoors because of COVID.
因为我们是如何进化的，在自然的粗犷中，我们对自然有一种亲和力和吸引力。所以，无论是窗外的真实景观还是墙上的景观照片，它都会吸引我们的注意力，让我们参与其中，它作为一种积极的干扰，让我们从任何可能让我们感到压力的事物、我们的疼痛中解脱出来，其他益处也随之而来，这是一种心理上的积极干扰。所以让我们谈谈新冠疫情以及我们可能能够继续做的事情。所以我们很多人因为新冠疫情而对室内有了不同的思考。
What are some of the things you think might change about the design of our indoor spaces that we're experimenting with now that we might keep when the pandemic is over? I think we might see people thinking more about flexibility and how we can design flexible spaces. Most directly related, you can think of hospitals, and you've seen hospital capacity just swell. I have talked to healthcare designers who have said
你认为我们现在正在试验的室内空间设计中，有哪些可能会改变，并且我们在疫情结束后可能会保留下来？我认为我们可能会看到人们更多地考虑灵活性以及我们如何设计灵活的空间。最直接相关的是，你可以想到医院，你已经看到医院的容量激增。我采访过医疗保健设计师，他们说
we want to think about how we can design hospitals that can suddenly treat many more patients if need be in the future. But even at the level of our home, we are suddenly having to carve out work spaces and classrooms in our homes, which we probably weren't expecting. And so I think we will see an emphasis on creating
我们想考虑如何设计医院，以便在未来需要时能够突然治疗更多的病人。但即使在我们的家庭层面，我们突然不得不从家中开辟工作空间和教室，这是我们可能没有预料到的。所以我认为我们将看到重点放在创造
homes and other buildings that have adaptive use or maybe flexible use of space, maybe partitions or movable room dividers, things like that I think will be helpful and in demand. And you know, even if you're building a house post-COVID, there could always be another pandemic or who knows what else, natural disasters, more uncertainty. And so I think the more we can create indoor spaces that we can quickly adapt for new uses, the better off we'll be. In we instance book is called The Great Indors, the surprising science of how buildings shape
具有适应性用途或也许是灵活空间用途的家庭和其他建筑，也许是隔断或可移动的房间隔板，我认为这些东西会有所帮助并且会有需求。而且你知道，即使你在疫情后盖房子，也总会有另一场大流行病，或者谁知道还有什么，自然灾害，更多的不确定性。所以我认为我们创造的室内空间越能快速适应新的用途，我们就越好。你的书叫《伟大的室内：建筑如何塑造
our behavior, health, and happiness. It's so good. It's a 99-Pi book. Through and through, you're going to love it. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Chris Baroubae, Music by Sean Riel. Our senior producer is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Drow Rosenberg, Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson, Happy Madonna, Katie Mingle, Sophia Klatsker,
我们的行为、健康和幸福的惊人科学》。它太棒了。这是一本99-Pi的书。自始至终，你会爱上它的。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。我们的高级制作人是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德罗·罗森伯格、薇薇安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、哈皮·麦当娜、凯蒂·明格尔、索菲亚·克拉茨克，
and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which lives at the far corners of North America right now, but is centered in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world, Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 K-A-L-W的一个项目，在“广播街”制作，它现在生活在北美最遥远的角落，但中心位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性的听众支持的、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体，在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。
You can tweet me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI or a current Instagram and write it too. And right now you can take care of all of your holiday shopping right now by ordering multiple copies of the 99% Invisible City at 99pi.org slash book. We have links to purchase it wherever you get your books, including Signed Editions, the audiobook, anywhere you want it.
你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI，或者在Instagram上关注，也可以写信。现在你可以通过在99pi.org/book订购多本《99%隐形城市》来完成你所有的节日购物。我们在你购买书籍的任何地方都有购买链接，包括签名版、有声读物，任何你想要的地方。
We can get it to you at the 99pi.org slash book. And for all your other 99pi needs, look no further than 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们可以在99pi.org/book为你提供。对于你所有的其他99pi需求，请查看99pi.org。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。